herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
auch heute wieder bomben russische
bomben auf die ukraine auf kiew und
andere große ukrainische städte seit
putins angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
seit dem 24 februar verstecken sich
menschen in kellern in luftschutzbunkern
und teilweise auch in metrostationen
oder aber sie fliehen nach angaben des
uno flüchtlingshilfswerks un hcr sind
seit beginn des russischen angriff auf
die ukraine inzwischen rund drei
millionen menschen auf der flucht haben
die ukraine verlassen mehr als 1,8
millionen davon sind in polen angekommen
und nach deutschland sind bisher laut
bundespolizei
175.000 gekommen man muss allerdings
dazu sagen so viele hat die
bundespolizei registrierte es dürften
viel viel viel viel viel mehr sein weil
es keine lückenlose kontrollen an den
grenzen gibt weil die ukraine 90 tage
wenn sie denn einen biometrischen pass
haben auch ohne registrierung nach
deutschland kommen können und insofern
dürfte die zahl an ukrainischen
flüchtlingen die in deutschland schon
angekommen sind noch sehr viel höher
sein und gar keine frage in den nächsten
tagen und wochen werden noch viele zu
uns kommen die diese flüchtlinge
aufnehmen was können wir für sie tun wie
wollen wir sie verteilen das ist das
thema darüber wollen wir heute sprechen
zum einen mit wohl deutschlands
bekanntesten migrationsforscher er als
klaus zuerst aber mit bianca bianca ist
eine freiwillige helferin
am hauptbahnhof in berlin hilft und hier
sagen vielen dank dass sie zeit hat
bianca ich hoffe man sieht sie jetzt
berlin ist der nabel der welt eine blaue
kugel aber jetzt haben wir sie endlich
doch bianca einen schönen guten darin
sind janka
zunächst einmal die frage wie viele
menschen kommen denn da eigentlich
täglich an
grob sind es ungefähr 10.000 leute plus
- die hier täglich am hauptbahnhof bei
uns in berlin ankommen das ist ja doch
eine ganze menge einfach mal beschreiben
was machen sie mit den menschen wie
helfen sie denen was brauchen die ich
kann mir nur vorstellen die kommen im
kleinen koffer an und haben ansonsten
nichts
ganz genauso sieht es aus wenn es
überhaupt ein koffer ist und mich nur
eine plastiktüte
wir freiwillige helfer haben es uns zur
aufgabe gemacht die leute wirklich vom
zug oben abzuholen sie dort in empfang
zu nehmen und sie dann weiter auf die
hier aufgebauten stationen zu verteilen
wir versuchen herauszufinden ob sie
entweder weiter reisen möchten oder in
berlin bleiben wollen oder in andere
bundesländer gebracht werden können um
dort erstmal unterkunft zu finden
genau ja das ist so ne das ist genau der
punkt eine frage die ich auch hätte was
sagen denn die menschen ich kann mir
vorstellen wenn jemand von haacke über
tage nach lemberg von lemberg dann nach
berlin angekommen ist dann ist man
kaputt etc aber sagen die menschen ich
möchte in berlin bleiben oder sagen die
dann wirklich ganz konkret ich habe
verwandte in hamburg da möchte ich hin
oder ich habe einen kussa in stuttgart
wie komme ich dahin was was fragen die
menschen lernen
das ist wirklich ganz unterschiedlich
auch die mentale verfassung der
geflüchteten die bei uns ankommen ist
ganz unterschiedlich es gibt leute die
gott sei dank familie oder freunde in
berlin oder in anderen bundesländern
haben oder auch in anderen ländern dann
versuchen wir sie bestmöglich dabei zu
unterstützen dort hinzukommen in bahn
tickets mit zu besorgen sie bei der
flugbuchung zu unterstützen etc der
großteil der hier ankommt würde ich
sagen hat aber erstmal gar keinen plan
das heißt sie stranden hier und wissen
erst mal nicht weiter und dann wird es
eben herauszufinden was sie für optionen
haben berlin ist jetzt nach zweieinhalb
wochen schon recht voll das heißt die
unterkünfte dies in berlin gibt
sind gerade für familien mit kindern
eher ungeeignet zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
die versuchen wir in
busse zu vermitteln wir haben busse die
vom senat organisiert wurden und diese
fahren eben in unterkünfte in anderen
bundesländern dort gibt es hotels
hostels jugendherbergen
sichere unterkünfte wurde leute erst mal
zur ruhe kommen können also das ist ja
auch eine interessante sache
jugendherberge hotel sind das am ende
dann auch turnhallen oder was sind das
für unterkünfte wenn man so viele in
berlin erstmal aufnimmt
mit sicherheit vor allem in berlin also
jetzt ist hier eben auch tegel oder der
stillgelegte flughafen tempelhof
die sind mit im gespräch als
unterkunftsmöglichkeiten dass es aber
wirklich natürlich keine langfristige
lösung das heißt dort können die leute
sie erstmal ausruhen und vielleicht ein
zwei tage dort bleiben und werden dann
eben weiter vermittelt gibt es denn
eigentlich irgendeine form von
registrierung also da kommt ein zug an
aus dem osten der kommt in berlin
hauptbahnhof an steht dann da jemand und
sagt wie heißen sie schreibt mal auf wo
wollen sie hin damit wir auch vielleicht
wissen wo sie am ende sind oder wie
läuft das ab
[Musik]
absolut gar nicht hier erfolgt überhaupt
keine registrierung deswegen sind die
zahlen der bisher in berlin angekommen
geflüchteten auch mit vorsicht zu
betrachten weil eben alle wissen dass
man sowieso 90 tage zeit hat sich zu
registrieren
aktuell erfolgt die registrierung nur
also man kann sich ein online termin
beim lms besorgen diese termine sind
aber für die nächsten vier wochen
bereits ausgebucht das heißt eine art
also eine registrierung erfolgt aktuell
überhaupt nicht also die menschen
steigen aus werden irgendwie verteilt
kommen irgendwo unter reisen weiter aber
die janka sie sagen es
und norman weiß dann keiner so richtig
wo es dahin wird oder wo wer ist gibt es
denn aber irgendeine unterstützung jetzt
von den behörden von dem land von der
stadt berlin
wir sind mittlerweile auch mit im
krisenstab zusammen mit dem berliner
senat der stadtmission der db der
polizei wir versuchen uns dort
einzubringen weil wir freiwilligen
helfer über die letzten zweieinhalb
wochen einfach eine sehr große expertise
aufbauen konnten und die möchten wir
auch gerne teilen wir möchten gerne dass
andere akteure auf unser wissen
zurückgreifen und wir sind gerne bereit
zu helfen leider war es in den letzten
wochen aber so dass wir wenn überhaupt
nur als punkt auf der to do liste mit
gesehen wurden was sehr schade ist weil
wir eben von tag eins an die am
hauptbahnhof mit dabei sind wir haben
ganz viel erlebt wir haben ganz viele
erfahrungen sammeln können und diese
erfahrungen kann sehr nützlich sein wenn
man darauf zurückgreift das heißt wir
würden uns absolut wünschen dass sich
die kommunikation dahingehend verbessert
dass wir mehr einbezogen werden dass
entscheidungen die getroffen werden mit
uns abgesprochen werden vor allem wenn
sie uns freiwillige hilfe involviert
helfer involvieren da wir häufig vor
vollendete tatsachen gesetzt werden und
gegebenenfalls sogar entscheidungen die
getroffen wurden
mit auffangen müssen es wurde dieses
zelt hier am washingtonplatz errichtet
und dort waren zb den ersten tagen
überhaupt keine russische oder
ukrainische sprachigen helfer vor ort
das heißt wir freiwilligen haben dort
dann unsere leute mit hingeschickt das
catering wurde vom senat mit übernommen
und 22 uhr sind die mitarbeiter gegangen
kurz bevor hier zwei züge mit über 1000
leuten eingetroffen sind und das sind
solche momente wo wir dann einspringen
weil es uns eben wichtig ist dass die
geflüchteten die hier ankommen wirklich
die bestmögliche versorgung erhalten
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir dann
mit einbezogen werden diese gespräche
und hat ihr das ja auch als als akteur
auf augenhöhe mit gesehen werden
wenn es eben krieg ist und man flüchten
muss spiele es keine rolle ob die
dienstzeiten zu ende sind es 22 uhr ist
so ein bisschen in die richtung geht
hier einen kommentar über facebook genau
christine kondziella schreibt die
politiker laden alle ein aber die arbeit
machen freiwillige vom staat keinerlei
unterstützung also höre ich da raus
sozusagen ein bisschen kritik dass die
unterstützung ja nicht gerade perfekt
ist und dass eben auch zu wenig auf sie
gehört wird
ich möchte niemanden angreifen das ist
absolut nicht unser ziel wir wollen
niemanden einen pranger stellen wir
wollen einfach nur daran appellieren
dass handlungsbedarf besteht und dass
man uns hört und dass die meisten
geflüchteten die bei uns ankommen in
berlin bei uns freiwilligen helfern
ankommen das heißt der großteil der
menschen die hier strand wird die landen
bei uns und dementsprechend ist es so
wichtig dass man uns in entscheidungen
mit einbezieht und uns eben nicht nur
als punkt auf der to do liste sieht
sondern mit uns gemeinsam an den
strukturen arbeitet wir haben super
strukturen eigenständig aufgebaut und
wir sind keine organisation wir sind
riesen kollektiv aus bestehend aus
privatpersonen haben uns mittlerweile
unter dem namen berliner team
zusammengefunden und haben
funktionierende strukturen geschaffen
bei denen die unterstützung brauchen vom
senat von der stadtmission von der
deutschen bahn
uns geht es einfach nur darum dass die
die hier ankommen eben das sind menschen
die aus dem krieg flüchten und das ist
nicht nur eine logistische
herausforderung wir wollen dass die
menschen hier mit würde behandelt werden
dass die bestmögliche versorgung
bekommen und nur dafür sind wir hier
bianca dann drängt sich so ein bisschen
die frage auf 2015 sind auch menschen
aus einem krieg geflüchtet es war halt
ein bürgerkrieg aber auch da sind
russische bomben gefallen syrien es
schreibt hier ein
chronicle 91 man kann also kurz und
knapp sagen die regierung hat nichts
gelernt aus 2015 alles läuft einfach
planlos wie beim thema corona etc ein
klarer kommentar aber meine frage wäre
tatsächlich wie ist jetzt ihr gefühl ist
man besser vorbereitet gewesen auf diese
flüchtlingswelle als 2015 oder ich sag
mal salopp geht das alles wieder
holterdiepolter
ich kann jetzt nur als meine private
meinung
kundtun ich habe nicht das gefühl dass
es 2015 gelernt wurde leider nicht dann
wollen wir hoffen dass vielleicht noch
einige kritikpunkte gehört worden sind
und sich eben einiges verbessert und sie
weiterhin helfen können zum abschluss
aber vielleicht doch etwas was ja auch
motiviert zu helfen die ärmel
hochzukrempeln
vielleicht beschreiben sie einfach mal
einen vielleicht ihr schönstes erlebnis
was sie jetzt erlebt haben es ist viel
arbeit sie sagen ja selbst wenn andere
nach hause gehen dann stehen sie da und
begrüßen die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
kinder vor allen dingen frauen und
kinder was ist denn vielleicht das
schönste erlebnis was ihnen jetzt in
erinnerung geblieben ist von diesem
vergangenen tag
ich will das gar nicht auf eine
spezielle situation eigentlich
beschränken es sind so viele situationen
die mir hier ganz lange noch im
gedächtnis bleiben werden ganz viel
dankbarkeit ganz viel liebe unter den
menschen selbst also zwischen den
freiwilligen helfern und dem
geflüchteten
hier kommen tiere kleine kinder alte
leute familien an wir versuchen den
bestmöglich zu helfen aber ich möchte
einfach auch nur die ja den moment
nutzen um noch mal daran zu appellieren
dass es ein paar ganz wichtige punkte
gibt die wir freiwillige helfer nicht
übernehmen können dass es zum beispiel
die medizinische versorgung und gerade
im hinblick auf die kommenden wochen der
krieg schreitet voran dh wir werden hier
wahrscheinlich noch mehr menschen
empfangen die es nicht mehr geschafft
haben rechtzeitig zu fliehen die
verletzt sind die psychologische
betreuung brauchen seit dieses zelt auf
dem spielplatz errichtet wurde haben wir
unten keine feste medizinische betreuung
mehr mit unten meine ich im ug 1 und da
kommt ungefähr eine dreiviertel der
geflüchteten an wir haben keine
russischen und ukraine sprachigen
psychologen dort vor ort und das sind
einfach dinge die wir die unsere
kompetenz überschreiten wir helfen gern
wir versuchen es nach besten wissen und
gewissen aber da besteht einfach ganz
akuter handlungsbedarf damit weiterhin
die geflüchteten die bei uns ankommen
sich gut aufgehoben fühlen damit die
weiterhin wir sind hier einfach die die
erste anlaufstelle wir wollen dass sich
hier alle willkommen fühlen dass sie mit
einem guten gefühl in die unterkünfte
weiterreisen können und dass sie eben
nicht nachts im kalten mit kind und
kegel vor diesem zelt stehen und wir
freiwilligen helfer dann decken bringen
müssen wir wollen dass es ihm gut geht
dass alle mit würde behandelt werden das
alle gut aufgenommen werden damit auch
weiterhin eben von positiven geschichten
berichtet werden
dann brauche ich gar nichts hinzufügen
liebe bianca denn am besten hat es
zusammengefasst samen ihrer über youtube
vielen dank schreibt sie an alle
freiwilligen helferinnen und helfer ihr
macht eine super arbeit und man kann nur
hoffen dass der staat endlich mal mehr
unterstützt mehrere leute danken den
freiwilligen helfern unter anderem eben
auch dank an sie dem kann ich mich
einfach nur anschließend sage vielen
vielen dank für das gespräch
ja und drücke die daumen dass ich die
arbeit das sich vielleicht einiges für
sie auch leichter wird dass die
unterstützung noch größer wird und dass
sie weiterhin viel freude und eine
erfolgreiche arbeit haben nämlich den
menschen helfen vielen dank
wir haben es eben schon gesagt ein
bisschen werden an so einem tag auch
erinnerungen wach erinnerungen die zum
vergleichen und zum ziehen von
parallelen animieren oder dazu anregen
2015 wir haben es gesagt der syrien
krieg da waren auch hunderttausende auf
der flucht flohen vor einem krieg auch
damals fielen russische bomben und
hunderttausende flohen eben richtung
europa und viele mit ihnen bevor wir
vergleichen die situation von damals und
heute das ganze analysieren
blicken wir das auf das was die für die
ukrainischen flüchtlinge heute im jahr
2022 gilt was die europäische union
entschieden hat wenn sie von der ukraine
richtung westen nach europa kommen da
sind drei punkte ganz wichtig
punkt eins die sogenannte massenzustrom
richtlinie der eu sie soll gewährleisten
dass alle schutzsuchenden aus der
ukraine aufgenommen werden
unbürokratisch
geflüchtete erhalten einen
vorübergehenden schutzstatus in der eu
zunächst für ein jahr sie dürfen
arbeiten zur schule gehen studieren
haben das recht auf medizinische
versorgung voraussetzung die
registrierung bei einer ausländerbehörde
punkt 2 geflüchtete aus der ukraine
müssen also keinen asylantrag stellen um
schutz zu bekommen damit fallen auch
aufwendige prüfungsverfahren wie etwa
2015 angewendet weg zum beispiel das
dublin-verfahren
das regelt zuständig ist das land in dem
schutzsuchende zuerst ankommen
punkt drei dieser freiheit menschen aus
der ukraine dürfen sich 90 tage in der
eu aufhalten ganz ohne visum unabhängig
vom krieg vorausgesetzt sie besitzen
einen biometrischen reisepass die
visafreiheit gilt inzwischen auch für
menschen aus drittstaaten die sich mit
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine aufgehalten
haben zum beispiel studierende
so ist es also heute was enel 2015 was
es vielleicht anders wir wollen darüber
reden und begrüßen gerald knaus von der
europäischen stabilitätsinitiative es
wohl derzeit einer der bekanntesten
flüchtlings politischen experten in
deutschland heraus schönen guten abend
toll dass die zeit haben vielen dank
frage an sie wenn die
flüchtlingswelle die 2015 ausgelöst war
durch den syrien krieg wenn sie das
vergleich mit der heutigen lage was ist
anders und was ist so ein bisschen doch
auch dieser wie
also
der
allerwichtigste unterschied liegt
zunächst einmal in der dimension der
herausforderung
wir hatten im jahr
2015 zwölf ausnahme monate in denen eine
bis dahin noch nie gekannte zahl von
menschen aus der türkei nach
griechenland und dann weiter richtung
deutschland und schweden gezogen sind
das war in einem jahr eine million
menschen
jetzt haben wir eine situation wo jede
woche eine million menschen in die
europäische union kommen also damals ein
jahr jetzt jede woche und das erklärt
glaube ich auch warum keine behörde kein
land vorbereitet war das ist jetzt schon
die größte flüchtlingsbewegung seit dem
ende des zweiten weltkrieges oder den
ereignissen kurz nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg in europa und das zweite was
anders ist haben sie gut beschrieben in
ihrem beitrag durch die historische
entscheidung nicht nur alle in der
ukraine leben herein zu lassen sondern
ihnen auch den status in der gesamt neo
zu garantieren gibt es viele vorteile
weil menschen die jemanden kennen die
verwandte haben freunde können sich
direkt dorthin begeben manche dinge sind
ein bisschen komplizierter weil man die
leute eben nicht sofort erfassen kann
sie müssen sich nicht sofort
registrieren aber das bietet insgesamt
eine große chance auch für eine mögliche
verteilung in europa wenn auch eines ist
klar wenn weiterhin jede woche eine
million menschen in die eu kommen und
das kann bis ende märz bedeuten dass
dann insgesamt fünf millionen
flüchtlinge in der eu sind dann ist die
kapazität von polen oder moldawien oder
den anderen nachbarn der ukraine jetzt
schon praktisch erschöpft und wenn dann
nicht eine verteilung auch in andere
länder europas gelingt dann werden sehr
viel mehr menschen nach deutschland
kommen als 2015 also wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe sozusagen das was jetzt
ein bisschen besser ist dass die eu
gesagt hat ihr habt einen status ihr
dürft euch in der gesamten eu aufhalten
und insofern gibt es jetzt die
möglichkeit wenn jemand sagt ich möchte
nach portugal war ich dann zu sagen dann
kann er da hin wenn dann nach dänemark
möchte dann kann er da hin wenn er nach
deutschland nach stuttgart möchte dann
eben auch dahin also anders als 2015 wo
ja sozusagen doch die grenzen sehr zu
gemacht worden sind habe ich das richtig
verstanden sozusagen das bedeutet ganz
praktisch dass wenn jetzt heute und
dafür habe ich geworben bei freunden ich
habe mit bürgermeister europäische
hauptstädte gesprochen wenn die
hauptstädte europas sagen würde wir sind
alle bereit jeweils zwei oder mehr
prozent unserer bevölkerung aufzunehmen
madrid london dublin dann muss man die
dort nur hinbringen also nach madrid
oder lissabon oder dublin da muss
niemand mehr zustimmen die schwierigkeit
liegt also nicht darin den rechtsstatus
zu klären jeder jeder ukrainerin kann
überall aufgenommen werden sondern das
zu organisieren das hast du die nächsten
zwei millionen die in der eu ankommen
nicht erst mit den zügen durch europa
ihren auf der suche nach einer
unterkunft sondern dass man sie
möglichst schon an aus moldawien dem
ärmsten land europas oder aus polen oder
eben auch aus ungarn oder deutschland
auch in länder bringt wo es ja die
geister die gibt sie in spanien irland
portugal wie in deutschland wo die aber
nicht von selbst ihm kommen würden und
das würde eine verteilung in europa
notwendig sein wird sehr stark
erleichtern also das heißt sie würden im
grunde eine art luftbrücke vorschlagen
von der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
sozusagen mit schild hoch wer hat
verwandte in portugal und dann der flug
nach portugal wehrt verwandte in italien
und dann was ich die busfahrt nach pisa
oder sowas in richtung
ja weil sehr viele die jetzt ankommen
keine verwandten in der eu haben das war
die erste welle die ersten menschen die
kamen die haben natürlich wenn ihre ihre
brüder väter in polen gearbeitet haben
oder ihre verwandten dann sind sie da
hin jetzt kommen viele und die die
wissen gar nicht wo sie hin können und
dann ist natürlich die das ist
psychologisch verständlich die idee das
kennen wir wir kennen in berlin und ich
glaube das ist auch ein grund für die
attraktivität der deutschen hauptstadt
aber am ende werden nicht alle in berlin
unter kommen und es wäre es sinnvoll und
wenn man sich die zahlen vor augen
führen wir doch klar worum es geht wenn
zwei millionen menschen in zwei wochen
kommen das ist ja bis ende märz bis ende
märz keine sehr kurze zeit wenn dann
zumindest eine million verteilt würde
auch in westeuropa
dann werden dass wir spanien 120.000
menschen und das muss man organisieren
das geht nicht spontan man muss den
menschen natürlich das vertrauen geben
dann muss sie aufklären da wird sie in
ein flugzeug steigen man muss ihnen
sagen dass das ja auch keine endgültige
entscheidung ist sie haben ja
visafreiheit das aber nicht chance
unterzukommen ihre kinder schneller in
schulen zu bringen auch eine unterkunft
zu finden natürlich viel größer ist wenn
nicht alle diese menschen wie jetzt in
warschau oder in naher zukunft in
deutschland an den gleichen plätzen sind
also die zahlen sie haben völlig recht
nicht wahr polen da sind schon in 17
millionen flüchtlinge angekommen in
warschau was so 1,7 millionen einwohner
hat 300.000 flüchtlinge also da kann man
schon verstehen dass jetzt nicht polen
oder die republik moldau auf weitere
flüchtlinge aufnehmen kann also es muss
verteilt werden aber es ist ja zum
beispiel so großbritannien da haben wir
auch schon berichte im zdf gehabt ja
sagt zwar wir wollen unterstützen wir
helfen etc aber wir haben schon gefühle
gestrandete ukrainische flüchtlinge
gesehen die nach großbritannien wollten
und jetzt in frankreich fest sitzen also
da gibt es ja auch eine gewisse
weigerung ist es so dass wenn wir aus
großbritannien außen vor lassen sie
optimistisch sind das jetzt doch
innerhalb der gesamten eu ja ich sag mal
die tore und türen offener sind
also innerhalb der gesamten eu gibt es
ja das recht das ist ja anders was mir
dann ist er nicht mehr mitglied
europäischen union aber auch dort glaube
ich wäre es wichtig und das war mein
vorschlag in den letzten tagen politiker
hier in berlin jetzt ein team zu
ernennen aus dem ehemaligen
ministerpräsidenten oder politikern die
den moralischen druck erhöhen die die
ministerpräsidenten und regierungschefs
über in europa anrufen und eben auch mit
pedro sanchez dem spanischen
ministerpräsidenten oder mit der
englischen regierung reden und sagen ihr
sagt ihr wollt helfen wir wir sind
überzeugt wenn ihr das so macht wie in
polen oder deutschland dann werden auch
bei euch viele freiwillige sagen wir
helfen aber wir müssen das jetzt
organisieren
das ist möglich aber man muss es auch
richtig präsentieren ehrlich
kommunizieren es geht hier um eine
mammutaufgabe die größte humanitäre
katastrophe seit jahrzehnten in europa
es geht aber auch um ein politisches
signal an wladimir putin
denn er hat sicherlich darauf gesetzt
durch seinen terror krieg die
vertreibung der zivilisten die
zerstörung der wahlbezirke die wir sehen
auch die bomben auf spitäler und schulen
eine große flüchtlingsbewegung in gang
zu setzen um europa zu schwächen er will
dass sich die europäer streiten er will
das in europa seine populistischen
freunde stärker werden und am liebsten
wäre ihnen das der europäer auch die
ukraine sei oder verstimmt sind und die
ukraine zurückweisen und das ist ihm
nicht gelungen die empathie ist
riesengroß aber etwa die ohne
organisation reicht nicht wir brauchen
also auch eine logistik und ich habe in
den letzten tagen und heute im bundestag
wurde das auch von abgeordneten so
präsentiert auf die berliner luftbrücke
wiesenbad sind 48 das schien auch
unmöglich dass man eine stadt wie berlin
gegenüberstanden erpressung und blockade
über ein jahr lang aus der luft versorgt
und es hat es ist gelungen zweieinhalb
millionen berliner aus der luft zu
versorgen das heißt die
einstellung der amerikaner gegenüber
deutschland der deutschen gegenüber
amerika kurz nach dem krieg drastisch
verändert jetzt geht es um eine ähnliche
humanitäre großtat und ein ergebnis wäre
dass die ukraine die kinder die wir
jetzt die aufnehmen ihre eltern dass der
einstellung zurück zum rest europas ich
natürlich auch drastisch verändern wird
in einer krise kommen wir zusammen und
dann entsteht aus dieser tragödie doch
noch etwas positives
und ich glaube der ministerpräsident von
sachsen hat das schön gesagt also sagte
wir wollen dass wir jetzt zu uns kommen
sich für den rest ihres lebens an diese
aufnahme erinnern mit der trage mit der
katastrophe daheim dass sie hier in
deutschland menschlichkeit gefunden
haben damit haben sie also skizziert was
solidarität und wirkliche hilfe
hilfsbereitschaft daneben noch in
späteren jahren eben erreichen kann
james heimen schreibt über facebook das
ist ja eine sehr sehr schöne sache
solche solidarität zu sehen jetzt kommt
die kritische anmerkung dennoch ist es
traurig das ist diese solidarität im
jahre 2014 15 bei den europäischen
ländern nicht zu sehen war das würde ja
bedeuten dass die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine mehr wert sind als die aus
syrien und afrika was sagen sie dazu
also ich bin seit jahren extrem kritisch
gegenüber der europäischen politik an
den außengrenzen auch im mittelmeer aber
man muss schon unterscheiden zwischen
einer situation wie jetzt wo allen klar
ist und das erklärt glaube ich warum
auch in polen die solidarität so groß
ist diese ukraine die fliegen können nur
nach europa fliegen das ist das einzige
zufluss ziel und in der frage der
kommunikation aus dem nahen osten war es
ja auch so dass die allermeisten den
nachbarn aufgenommen wurden so wie auch
kolumbien seine grenzen geöffnet dort
für 1,8 millionen menschen aus venezuela
es ist eben so dass in einer
gesellschaft
die empathie bei einer breiten gruppe
von menschen damals stärksten ist wenn
man die wii kommen irgendwie kennt wenn
man sich mit ihnen irgendwie
identifiziert und 2015 gab es diese
empathie ja in deutschland auch in
schweden ab für die syrer man man wusste
was ihnen widerfährt man wusste auch sie
flohen vor dem krieg aber nicht überall
in europa wurde soviel über den syrien
krieg berichtet und so wie wir heute
nicht ähnlich viel höheren über die
tragödie im jemen oder im kongo oder in
anderen kriegsgebieten äthiopien und
daher nicht die gleiche energie entsteht
so ist für etwa die eben immer auch die
aufmerksamkeit notwendig also es wundert
mich jetzt nicht dass empathie für
nachbarn und in diesem fall für menschen
über die wir sehr sehr viel höheren der
leitende direkten und die direkt zu uns
kommen das sind ja nur einige stunden
autofahrt in vielen fällen dass die bei
der breiten bevölkerung leichter
entsteht
damit also den punkt ganz gut erklärt
was james sein wenn hier gefragt hat
kommen wir zu einer anderen frage zur
kritik wir haben ja eben mit bianca
gesprochen er hat im grunde auch
deutlich gemacht
registrierung findet im grunde genommen
nicht statt da kommt ein zug an man
hilft den menschen schnell unterstützung
von der stadt gar nicht mal so sehr sind
viele freiwillige helfer aber wer dann
wo genau am ende ist gibt es nicht jetzt
die union cdu/csu derzeitig heftige
kritik an dem ganzen handling dieser
flüchtlingskrise die kritik richtet sich
vor allen dingen an die bundes
innenministerin und aus der die kritik
geht eben dahin dass auch diese
lückenhafte kenntnis über die
einreisenden und die forderung nach
grenzkontrollen kommt die
innenministerin wiederum entgegnet und
sagt dass er schlicht die rechtslage
keine grenzkontrollen zu haben weil
diese menschen ja aufgrund der
eu-entscheidung einfach ohne visum
einfach mit ihrem pass in europa
einreisen können wie sehen sie diese
kritik das nicht registriert wird
sehen sie das als ähnliches chaos wie
2015 oder hat die innenministerin recht
das ist doch eine ganz andere geschichte
also ich glaube zunächst mal ist es eine
andere geschichte weil die
innenministerin rechts hat darin dass
diese ukrainischen
frauen und kinder vor allem die
einreisen das recht haben für
90 tage sich frei in der ganzen eu zu
bewegen und so wie sich touristen nicht
überall registrieren müssen sie sich
nicht registrieren andererseits verstehe
ich die frustration in den ländern auch
bei vielen die dafür zuständig sind die
unterkunft vorzubereiten dass die sagen
wie sollen wir das machen wenn wir nicht
wissen wie viele wohin kommen und die
dritte herausforderung ist neben die
zuweisung wenn sich menschen frei
überall bewegen und damit sehr sehr viel
leben sagen wir wollen in eine stadt von
der wir gehört haben aber wir wollen
nicht in andere städte oder kleinere
städte die wir nicht kennen aber
es nicht genug platz gibt dann muss man
menschen verteilen das sieht die
schwierigkeiten und ich glaube was wir
jetzt erleben ist ein zusammenkommen der
länder mit dem innenministerium und wo
man versucht das
gemeinsam unter ein dach zu bringen es
ist so menschen können sich in
deutschland frei bewegt auch die ukraine
dürfen das aber die idee mit dem
königsteiner schlüssel menschen
zuzuweisen die tritt dann in kraft und
darüber wird jetzt diskutiert wenn
menschen eine leistung also
unterstützung einen platz in der schule
unterstützung fürs wohnen oder zunächst
mal ein dach über den kopf bekommen und
da ist es natürlich sinnvoll und das
haben viele landespolitiker in den
letzten tagen gesagt wenn man einen
schlüssel hat also dass nicht alle
menschen in einigen wenigen
bundesländern sind oder da gibt es dann
zu wenig von allem medizinische
versorgung und schule und zu wenige
anderswo aber es wird ja jetzt beginnen
eine zuteilung von denen die keine
bekannten oder freunde haben ich habe
gerade mit einem politiker in baden
württemberg gesprochen da beginnt morgen
kommen die ersten 2000 wie zugewiesen
werden sollen das wird man dem ganzen
bundesgebiet zu sein und das wird die
situation natürlich auch für die gebiete
wie berlin war jetzt besonders viele
sind leichter machen das zu berechtigen
jetzt haben sie ihn zweimal erwähnt den
begriff den königsteiner schlüssel den
wollen wir natürlich erklären denn sie
haben den wichtigen punkt angeschnitten
die innenministerin frau feser sagt eben
wenn die menschen nicht privat
unterkommen dann sollen sie eben nach
einem schlüssel nach bevölkerungsgröße
und wirtschaftskraft auf die
bundesländer verteilt werden der
königssteiner schlüssel schauen wir
unseren kurzen beitrag einfach mal an
was das genau ist
jeden tag kommen zehntausende
geflüchtete aus der ukraine in
deutschland an ein teil von ihnen hat
verwandte oder freunde hier und bestimmt
seinen aufenthaltsort selbst die anderen
sollen möglichst fair auf die
bundesländer verteilt werden nach dem
sogenannten königsteiner schlüssel
er sieht vor dass das land berlin wo
besonders viele flüchtlinge ankommen gut
fünf prozent aufnehmen soll das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
nordrhein westfalen soll 21 prozent der
geflüchteten eine längerfristige
unterkunft bieten baden württemberg und
bayern 13 bzw knapp 16 prozent
für die anderen bundesländer sind
niedrigere quoten vorgesehen fest steht
das ganze wird ein kraftakt für die
geflüchteten und die helfenden
ja frage an sie der sich mit der ganzen
migration verteilung königsberger
schlüssel auskennt funktioniert das denn
am ende dann wirklich in der praxis
also ich glaube was wir jetzt brauchen
die nächsten wochen als als bürger
bürger reden auch als medien und
beobachter ist ein verständnis von der
außergewöhnlichen situation denn wir
werden ganz ganz vielen dingen die nicht
funktionieren über menschen die
irgendwann geschickt werden sollten da
nicht hin wollen über städte wo es zu
wenig infrastruktur gibt ihr reden wie
gesagt über ein historisches phänomen
aber am ende ist natürlich die
zusammenarbeit aller bundesländer und
eine faire verteilung der
beste weg um sicherzustellen dass
möglichst schnell vor allem auch die
große zahl von kindern in schulen einen
platz finden wenn alle menschen in
einigen münchen sich damen beiden würden
und niemand in andere landkreise bayerns
verteilt würde dann wäre es sehr viel
schwieriger die soziale infrastruktur
bereitzustellen und ich bin überzeugt
mit den schwierigkeiten mit dem chaos
das wir die nächsten wochen sicher noch
sehen werden weil es komme nicht bei
jedem tag sehr viele neue menschen dazu
am ende ist deutschland und nachher 2015
auch sicher nicht geholfen
in der lage das zu lösen ein hoher
beamter in einer großen ausländer würde
gesagt 2015 ist auch im vergleich zu den
zahlen von heute eine art übung gewesen
also die echte herausforderung kommt
heute
ja und ich bin nach den letzten tagen
und vielen gesprächen
durch die enorme empathie und das
engagement der helfer und auch durch das
bewusstsein in den ministerien wie ernst
die herausforderung ist was ist jetzt da
und dann wird bin ich jetzt
optimistischer
dass das auch wirklich bewältigt werden
kann in deutschland wie das in anderen
teilen europas ist das werden wir noch
sehen
haben beitrag schon gehört das ist ein
kraftakt eine mammutaufgabe sagen sie ja
auch bayern hören wir heute stellt
seinen kommunen zur unterbringung und
versorgung der aus der ukraine kommenden
flüchtlinge eine milliarde euro zur
verfügung ein bundesland wie bayern
könne diese kosten mal vorstrecken sei
ja reich andere bundesländer hätten sich
damit schwerer sagte der
ministerpräsident aus bayern markus
söder heute und hat ein klares signal an
den kanzler gesendet dass der bund doch
bitte bei den kosten die kosten
übernehmen müsste jetzt gibt es morgen
diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
zwischen allen ministerpräsidenten und
dann ist herr scholz dabei wird da ganz
schön krachen denn so eine unterbringung
etc wir haben es ja gerade gesehen
kostet ja eben auch viel geld
also wenn ich zurück schafft die letzten
großen krisen nicht nur die
flüchtlingsbewegung 215 auch den beginn
der korona pandemie als es ja auch darum
gegen mit sehr viel geld
zusammenbruch von vielen betrieben und
die arbeitsplätze zu erhalten den
zusammenbruch zu verhindern dann die
versuche in der europäischen union mit
einem wiederaufbau fonds auch andere
länder in der union zu unterstützen
das ist eine regierung das war ein
finanzminister und ist jetzt auch ein
bundeskanzler scholz der in der
historischen momenten erkannt hat dass
es jetzt werde ich darauf ankommt so zu
handeln dass es erfolgreich ist und das
bedeutet auch auf die länder und
kommunen einzugehen ich bin da am ende
optimistisch
deutschland weiß und ich glaube das
spüren viele bürger und bürgerinnen das
spürt auch die politik man hat versagt
in der außenpolitik und den krieg in der
ukraine nicht rechtzeitig verhindern
können man hat putin die falschen
signale gegeben man hat russland falsch
eingeschätzt man auch die ukraine zu
wenig unterstützt und der krieg ist
gekommen aber die eine sache und das ist
glaube ich auch bei den innenministern
bewusst und wird sie zu kompromissen
bringen wie jeder weiß ist die eine
sache die heute jeder in deutschland und
in europa machen kann ist den kindern
und frauen und verwandten der ukraine
die jetzt kämpfen um ihr land und ihre
demokratie zu erhalten eine möglichst um
eine aufnahme zu ermöglichen das ist
etwas was jeder von uns tun kann und in
den letzten tagen war ich bei vielen
politikern war einigen redaktionen und
überall treffe ich leute die wir dann
sagen ja wir haben ein zimmer gewohnten
wir nehmen jemanden auf in der heute ein
kameramann der besagt ja ich habe jetzt
nach seinem gespräch ja ich habe jetzt
auch ein zimmer freigeräumt
diese empathie wenn die innenminister
die morgen zusammensitzen spüren wie die
bevölkerung damit umgeht und ohne jede
center mit sentimentalität es wird
schwierig es wird probleme geben aber
die bereitschaft ist da wenn die
innenminister das spüren dann und und
die landesminister präsidenten dann wird
es kompromisse geben am geld wird es in
dieser situation auf kosten der frauen
und kinder die hier sind nicht scheitern
dann kann es eigentlich kein besseres
schlusswort geben was voller optimismus
ist sie haben uns nochmal deutlich
gemacht wie solidarität ein kleines kern
ist wo dann doch etwas wachsen kann was
auch für die zukunft wichtig ist und es
ist ja schön zu sagen
schön zu von ihnen zu hören dass man
sagt
2015 das war eine übung jetzt kriegen
wir das vielleicht auch gewuppt und eben
mit dieser hilfe der freiwilligen wir
haben bianca gesehen da müsste das ein
signal auch an die politik gehen dass
man da unkompliziert hilft und insofern
am 7 rund um das gesagt was alexandra
dakar die uns per e-mail geschrieben hat
das geht in die gleiche richtung ein
bisschen weniger bürokratie täter
deutschland gut wir brauchen
pragmatische und effiziente lösungen
schreibt sie deutschland soll aus den
bisherigen flüchtlingswellen etwas
gelernt haben solidarität steht an
erster stelle sagt sie und nicht der
interne streit vorüber wer wieviele
aufnehmen kann wer was bezahlen muss
dazu bleibt uns keine zeit insofern
stimmen sie beide über ein und wir sagen
großes dankeschön für ihre expertise
einschätzungen wünschen einen schönen
abend heraus vielen dank schöne damen
davon sie danke schön ja das war unser
zdf heute live zum thema wie wir die
flüchtlinge verteilen können die aus der
ukraine kommen was deutschland was
europa tun kann und wir haben es gehört
von herrn klaus mit der solidarität wenn
jeder anpackt und vielleicht ein zimmer
frei räumt dann könnte das alles klappen
und kann man den ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer hier eine neue heimat bieten
vielen dank für ihr interesse ihre
beteiligung einen schönen abend noch
fürs und auch wieder